le président russe s'est globalement
félicité de la façon dont a été gérée la
crise dans son pays en commençant par la
fermeture rapide des frontières de la
russie en particulier avec la chine dès
les premiers moments de cette crise
sanitaire mais aussi à propos du système
de santé russes qui a globalement bien
encaissé le choc un chiffre pour
illustrer ce fait
l'arc la russie disposées au début de
cette crise de quarante mille lits pour
recueillir pour recevoir les malades du
corps n'avait russe on en est
aujourd'hui à 120 milles et ce chiffre
va demeurer constant jusqu'à ce que
soient complètement enrayé cette crise
du coc vide 19 alors oui la menace recul
mais elle est toujours bien présente et
ne faut pas baisser la garde
comme l'a rappelé vladimir poutine tant
qu'un vaccin n'est pas mise au point il
distribuer aux plus grands noms encore
aujourd'hui des milliers de personnes
chaque jour deviennent malades
donc je vous prie d'être vigilant
prudents jusqu'à ce que la production de
masse de médicaments
soit lancée aujourd'hui nos spécialistes
travaillent à l'élaboration à la
conception d'un vaccin les premiers
essais ont commencé je comprends bien
que tout le monde voudrait que un tel
médicament utile vienne le plus vite
possible mais les medics les médecins
s'en tiennent aux principes de sûreté de
sécurité et cela concerne toutes les
classes d'âge de la population
vladimir poutine a également rappelé que
la conservation des emplois et des
salaires a toujours été sa priorité en
témoignent les mesures de période chômée
mais rémunéré adopté dès le début de la
période de confinement et pour relancer
l'activité économique
plusieurs mesures ont été annoncées en
particulier la poursuite des allocations
familiales exceptionnel l'accès facilité
au crédit immobilier ou encore la hausse
de l'impôt sur le revenu mais uniquement
sur les ménages disposant d'un certain
niveau de ressources enfin il a eu un
mot concernant la grande consultation
populaire du 1er juillet concernant les
amendements à la constitution il a fait
savoir qu'il n'entrerait en vigueur ces
amendements constitutionnels que s'ils
étaient soutenus par la population